AND PUSH IT ACROSS AND SCORE. PS
ACROSS THE SEAM TO
CARLSON TO THE GOAL LINE BUT
HALFWAY UP THE WALL NEAR SIDE
FOR
HINOSTROZA BEHIND  JUSTIFY. AND
AND NICE DECISION KEEPING UP HE
THE NE A LITTLE END-TO-END
PUSH BY THE WORK HORSE FROM SCO!
WILL BUTCHER JUMPS INTO THE
COZENS KEEPS DRIVING THROUGH TO
THE NET AND PUL THEIR OWN ZONE.
ASPLUND TOUCHES IT AHEAD.
HA GETTING A CHANCE
AND PLENTY OF ICE TIME.
THE MORE HE PLAYS, THE MORE
CONF OWN NET.
IN THE SLOT.L
WITH A SHOT OFF THE POST! FEHER
SCORES WITH A ONE TIMER!.
WASHINGTON WILL BRING THREE BACK
TO CENTER ICE.
PA
for what we need.
ON OVER THE LINE AND TO
THE WING. WITH 5:31 TO GO IN
THE THIRD PERIOD.
If you're an adult
newly diagnosed
with non-small cell lung cancer
that's spread
COZENS.
WILL SETTLE TOP OF THE
CIRCLE AND
OF THE YEAR.
COMING ON 19 POINTS TO THE
CAPITALS   IN THE OVERTIME.
WON'T GET IT.
TOUGH PLALAN.
THOMPSON FORCED OUTSIDE THE
FOUR SECONDS.
DAHLIN LOOKS AT THE CLOCK.IN FA
>> Dan:
IS CLOSED.
>> Ron: HE HAD IT OPEN AND AT
THE LAST SECOND PIN PRESSURE HE.
HE'S A SHOOTER.
HE HAS GOT TO BE SHOOTING IN
BETWEEN THE CIRCLES.
OSHIE SCORES.